why don't we
it's so good to see you guys how you
been so long i feel like it's been good
been really good yeah it has been years
since i have seen you guys last y'all
are grown up we've got makeup on
look at this
it's a first honestly i never do it
really yeah no what made you want to do
it tonight i was getting my makeup done
uh like just the normal touch-ups the
touch-ups and then uh the makeup lady
goes
yo i kind of want to put some eyeliner
on and i was like okay okay
i had to get the decision he looks so
sexy he looks bad all black everything
including the makeup now do you guys
coordinate this look by the way loving
the dior moment
it's my mom's no i'm just kidding
but this lady coming in she's like i
have the white version that's a girl's
shirt right i was like yeah
rocky
rocking it
yeah we coordinated all black you you
got our stickers
oh we just i might break your outfit
here on the red carpet i think this is a
rental i don't know
we gotta give that back by the end of
the night i don't want to break i'm
gonna move an inch away from you
you guys
again so good to see you you're back
with new music you guys have been on a
jur knee to say the least how does it
feel to be here where you guys are at
right now in your career
there's been a lot of bumps in the road
in the last i mean covid was a start but
for us there's a lot of stuff going on
and
being on this carpet feels so good
because i feel like everyone's been
dying to do what they love doing again
and this is like a big portion of that
so we're happy to be here it feels good
to dress up and all you know do the
makeup
release music too yeah i'm coming back
live shows we're trying to plan a tour
right now so yeah everything feels good
so 2022 will be a good year for you guys
absolutely absolutely we have so much
plan it's gonna be amazing
who are you guys excited to see tonight
i'm stoked to see olivia she had an
insane year bts
yeah bts is going to kill it bts and
coldplay come on
they're doing two songs right is that
yeah
personal reasons we don't know but it's
okay bts is still gonna kill it i love
you doing dynamite
no i don't know they're doing my
universe with coldplay and then butter
that's a great song that's a legendary
great song no we got to talk about your
guys's new christmas song really quick
mistletoe you covered justin bieber's
mistletoe why that song i mean it's
great not that song you know i mean who
has ever covered justin bieber's
mistletoe someone's got to do it you
know yeah no but like but like dropped
it yeah yeah
an actual like actual spotify right here
i never ever cover mistletoe yeah we
were the first ones ever breaking news
groundbreaking here you guys
congratulations on everything hopefully
it's not another like three four years
before i see you guys again but good to
see you take care and have so much fun
tonight